hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my preview of all the big TV
shows that are coming this summer
there's there's actually quite a few
that are premiering I might not do
videos for all them on a weekly basis
but I'll at least be doing some of the
Premier's a lot of you have also been
asking me about shows that are on break
I will be doing weekly bonus videos for
pretty much everything that I normally
do videos for that means the flash game
of thrones all that stuff while it's on
break so don't worry about that but
these are all new shows that are
starting this summer so big stuff first
Jonathan strange & Mr Norrell it might
not be something that you guys have
heard of before some of you may have
read the book you can think of it as a
grownup version of Harry Potter like a
game of fairy Thrones there are actually
a couple of similarities to Game of
Thrones it's a revisionist history tale
like in the same way Harry Potter is you
know where by magic exists in the real
world where this series picks up it's
been gone for 300 years so these two
people have to bring it back if you
remember during Game of Thrones Season
one you know dragons were gone nobody
believed in magic but it was said to
have existed in the past come to the end
of that season you know you find dragons
come back into the world and we get to
see some magic in season 2 from
Melisandre this is a British drama so
the tone is a little bit different Game
of Thrones is an american series
produced internationally so it feels
much more like an HBO American series
this is a BBC series if you've never
watched British drama before it just it
plays a little bit differently but it's
still a lot of fun there's seven
episodes total and they're basically
doing the entire story from the book
that Susanna Clarke wrote they haven't
said whether or not they're doing a
season two but Susanna Clark is working
on a sequel novel she started in 2004
it's been about 10 years it took her
about 10 years to write the first novel
so even if she doesn't finish with that
second book they should have enough
material to do a season 2 it's already
started airing in the UK so what's
probably gonna happen is is I'll
probably wait till it premieres in the
US to do my episode 1 video what I'll
probably do is an episode at the
beginning of the season and then I'll do
a review of the entire season when it's
all over next up is doctor who series 9
that's going to be at the end of August
just like last year that would put it on
August 22nd for episode 1 if you've
never watched Doctor Who before this is
a good time to jump on I know everyone
always asks questions about Doctor Who
because there's such a long his
I try to make my Doctor Who videos
assuming that you know you haven't
watched like the entire history of
Doctor Who so don't worry Peter Capaldi
was a great doctor so I'm looking
forward to him coming back Jenna Coleman
is coming back as the companion and
missy or you know the master however you
want to think about her is gonna be big
character too way bigger than she was
last season next show after that is fear
the walking dead that's going to
premiere around the same time but they
haven't confirmed an official date yet
just like they do every year they will
be bringing a whole bunch of new footage
to comic-con that's the first week in
July that's the good thing they've been
pretty vague about when that shows going
to start but it's six episodes just like
they did for Walking Dead Season one
what happened is is whenever the walking
dead first aired a couple years ago they
did six episodes for season one I guess
just to see how it would do and then
when season two rolled around they got a
full season so they'll probably do that
with fear the walking dead the spin-off
show is a prequel it picks up when rick
is in his coma like right around the
time of the outbreak they did say the
timeline of the show would catch up with
the main show eventually so maybe in
like season 2 or season 3 of fear the
walking dead they'll run concurrently
but they're probably going to do is air
all the episodes of fear the walking
dead in the lead-up to the season 6
premiere the main show the main show
always premieres the second week in
October so you know just doing reverse
math they could either start fear the
walking dead at the end of august or the
beginning of September the problem with
that is that they said it would start
airing at the end of the summer in
September is not the summer so we'll
have to wait till they do that big comic
con panel at the beginning of July to
announce that official date don't worry
there'll be a whole bunch of trailer
footage they'll probably screen the
first episode there so I'll do
non-spoilery reviews of all that stuff
but Robert Kirkman is much more involved
with the spin-off show than he is with
the main show so if you're big fan of
the comics and Robert Kirkman you will
enjoy the spin-off show moving under the
smaller stuff so Star Wars rebels is
going to air their first episode June
twentieth that's called the siege of
Lothal they screened it for the first
time back in April at Star Wars
Celebration but most you will be seeing
it for the first time the regular series
though will pick up in October just like
it did last year Freddie Prinze jr. is
always really funny when he talks about
the series he did say that it would have
doubled the episodes of season one
that's not confirmed that would they'll
put it somewhere between like 20 22
episodes the guardians of the galaxy
cartoon that I just posted the trailer
four is supposed to air at the end of
the summer there's no official date so
I'm expecting August but because delays
are so common in the world of animation
I wouldn't be surprised if they push the
premiere to September there's a whole
bunch of the stuff that i will be making
content for on twitter and facebook
there are links for that in the
description but here's a rundown of like
all the other stuff Hannibal season
three starts on june fourth they're
building it is like the bride of
Hannibal with gillian anderson it looks
spectacular and terrifying i don't think
i'll be doing a lot of videos for it but
i will be at least be doing stuff on
facebook and twitter then a little bit
after that on jun 12 the people that
made Stargate Atlantis have a new show
called Dark Matter premiering on sci-fi
right now it's the only space opera that
there is so I would recommend you check
it out true detective season two starts
on jun 21st that's HBO of course I'll at
least do a video for the premiere the
only thing that worries me about this
season is that they took a lot of the
mythology out of the show like a lot of
the really trippy stuff that made season
one awesome the rock also does have a
new show on HBO it's called bollards
it's basically like entourage for sports
people I'm not planning on doing videos
for it but I'm going to check it out at
the end of June teen wolf season five
starts and scream The Scream series is
based on the film's if you guys watched
eros in as part of that series that's
why she's not on arrow I'm not planning
on doing Teen Wolf videos but i will
watch because it's probably gonna be the
last season of Teen Wolf penny dreadful
is on showtime it's still in the middle
of its run it's it's a Sunday night's
show I'd recommend you check it out I
don't know that I'm going to be doing
videos for it but it's spectacular I
know everybody's really excited about
the new x-files miniseries they're doing
early next year David Duchovny and
Gillian Anderson right now David
Duchovny has a series called Aquarius
you can stream all the episodes for free
on NBC com think of it as like an
x-files miniseries built around the
mystery of Charles Manson it's super
dark it just so happens that Renly
Baratheon from Game of Thrones is
playing Charles Manson so that should
get somebody excited at least so that's
just a quick rundown of some of the big
stuff that's happening in the next
couple months I you know I will do
preview videos whenever seasons get
ready to start so don't worry because
Comic Con is happening so early this
year I'll start to do preview videos for
comic-con in a couple weeks too so be
sure to subscribe to get that I have a
pretty good idea of the type of stuff
I'm going to be doing there there is a
rumor that
Marvel is not going to go but they
haven't confirmed that yet they'll
probably wait till the last minute to
say yes or no this year is going to be
really huge for all the DC TV shows and
the Warner Brothers DC movies they will
be bringing a ton of footage it's
gonna be awesome if there's anything
specific that you guys want to request
that I didn't mention just let me know
in the comments if there's something
that you guys really want but I don't
have time to do like full weekly videos
for I'll at least try to do something on
Facebook I don't have anybody helping me
yet like I still do all this stuff by
myself but hopefully by the fall I will
have like a helper so it'll be a little
bit easier for me to do stuff if you're
confused about the bonus video schedule
the days that videos would normally post
will be the days that bonus videos
typically pose like the flash airs on
tuesdays that's usually when my videos
post that's the day that bonus videos
for that will post usually every morning
i'll post on Twitter and Facebook the
video schedule for the day so if you
ever curious you know just check Twitter
and Facebook so don't forget about new
game of thrones tomorrow i'll be posting
a bonus video and then my episode video
just like normal why you guys wait for
that stuff to post you can click here
for last week's episode and you can
click here to learn all about Maester
Aemon thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you